wir haben an der dreckigsten strommixe
Europas und historisch gesehen ist
Deutschland das Land das
am vieles für die Klimakrise trägt das
ist das gigantisch deswegen nochmal die
Frage etwas was so CO2 bei allem Risiko
die das hat aber CO2-arm ist wie
atomkraft ist nicht das etwas über das
man vielleicht mal ganz unidologisch
nachdenken muss zumindest für die Zeit
bis wir es geschafft haben all die
Windräder und all die
Photovoltaik-Anlagen zu installieren die
wir brauchen um irgendwann unabhängig
davon zu sein man oft wenn man über neue
erneuerbare Energien spricht so tut als
würden erneuerbare Energien wahnsinnig
lange brauchen und alles andere sei
irgendwie schneller
aufzubauen braucht man unfassbar viel
Infrastruktur großartige Summen an
Geldern und dann muss man überlegen soll
das gasher kommt das ist ein
langfristiges Investment und das ist ein
großes Problem das gerade so viel von
diesen langen langfristigen Geldern in
fossile Energien gehen erneuerbare
können wenn die Bürokratie stimmt wenn
die Genehmigung stimmen und die Flächen
bereitgestellt werden unfassbar schnell
ganz ganz viele Leistungen und wir sind
in Deutschland das können Sie das auch
berechnen das zeigen die Studien immer
wieder wir sind in Deutschland in dieser
total schön komfortablen Situationen
dass wir aus der Kohle und aus der
Kernkraft aussteigen können wenn wir
bereit sind full on die Erneuerbaren zu
pushen das ist politisch auch sozusagen
schon eigentlich entschieden dass man
das will auf Jahre und das kann man
weitermachen naja das will ich ist es
ein Projekt das nicht von heute auf
morgen geht aber das ist eigentlich der
Weg auf den sich die Bundesregierung
aufmachen möchte und das jetzt aber auch
Geschichte aus meinem ehemaligen
Wahlkreis erzählt da wird eine
Umgehungsstraße gebaut soll gebaut
werden die der 10 oder 15 Jahren nicht
vorankommt weil drei Leute dagegen sind
ja das Thema will ich jetzt gar nicht
vertiefen ich würde sagen das dauert
lange jetzt heißt es die Erneuerbaren
sind wichtig also müssen wir jetzt die
Genehmigungsverfahren so verkürzen ist
keiner mehr mitreden darf und da sagen
meine ehemaligen Wählerinnen und Wähler
oder die da leben die sagen ihr habt ja
schön gut reden ich habe die schlechte
Sicht die Vögel werden geschreddert
jetzt plötzlich geht es schnell und ich
warte 15 Jahre auf die Umgehungsstraße
da ging es nicht so schnell das ist
nicht in Ordnung da entsteht aus
Demokratie heraus ist im Ergebnis
weniger wert so so das heißt ich bin
dafür Planungsverfahren zu verkürzen
auch anderswo nicht nur jetzt da auch
zum Beispiel verschiedenen Verkehre was
ziemlich was ein ziemlicher Eingriff in
die Natur ist wenn ich eine tr Tasse
München Berlin
Leuchtturmprojekt deutscher Einheit Mami
Peter Ramsau hier gesprochen 25 Jahre
gedauert sehr komplizierte tunnelwerke
zum Thema so schnell können wir sagen
ich will nur sagen zu sagen jetzt muss
das ganz schnell gehen ausgerechnet da
während wir generell denke ich schneller
werden müssen das scheint mir auch ein
problemwechsel in diesem Land zu tun
also es gab eine Wahl und es gibt jetzt
eine neue Koalition im Bund und an der
ihre Partei nicht mehr beteiligt wir
wissen das alle und da hat der Frau
Neuber auch irgendwie recht ja also an
welchem Punkt sind die denn wo haben die
angefangen energiepolitisch ja und das
jetzt ich habe im Moment das muss ich
immer sagen ja überhaupt nicht den
Eindruck dass es irgendwie das in diesem
Land der Wille allzu groß ist zu
beharren und zurückzugehen vielleicht
bei der AFD und bei Teilen der Union
aber eigentlich ist auch klar und und
Konsens würde ich mal sagen in diesem
Land
wollen die Erneuerbaren eine
andererseits denke ich ist es glaube ich
und nicht realistisch zu sagen also Sie
haben ja selber sie haben glaube ich
vier oder fünf wenn es aufgezählt jetzt
gerade
so ist es eben nicht und und wenn die
Leute eine kalte Wohnung haben dann
müssen wir leider auch pragmatisch sein
ich wollte auch noch mal ein Gedanken zu
diesem thunbergsatz sagen als ich das
gehört und gelesen habe dachte ich das
ist ein Gedanke von Nachhaltigkeit also
ganz
eben eine zeitgemäße oder von den
Ereignissen getriebene Nachhaltigkeit
biologisch ja also ich will die dafür
nicht abfeiern das ist irgendwie ich
glaube nicht dass sich ihr Leben lang
darauf gefreut hat sowas mal zu sagen
aber es ist halt ja eine politische
Nachhaltigkeit in diesem Moment habe ich
gedacht okay die Dinger stehen da ja und
ich weiß das ist jetzt nicht das rettet
hier nicht das Land aus der dieser Krise
aber es bewirkt etwas genauso wie im
Tempolimit auch was bewirken würde ja
wenn wir es endlich mal hätten
aber
es ist
ein Moment gewesen wo ich dachte das ist
total pragmatisch was die Frau da gerade
sagt das hätte ich dir niemals zugetraut
würden sie sich so ein Satz auch trauen
von Neubauer wow seit wann also ich kann
also ich muss mich jetzt nicht trauen
irgendein Satz zu sagen ich glaube ich
kann sagen
das ist ein Technologie die extrem
gefährlich ist viele Menschen in diesem
Land haben sehr lange erfolgreich und
aus guten Gründen dagegen gekämpft und
wenn wir die Möglichkeit haben da
rauszusteigen antworten so in der
Sendung nö das ist genau wenn wir die
Möglichkeit haben von der Atomkraft
wegzukommen und die technischen
Möglichkeiten haben wir die politischen
Festlegungen sind da so dann zum Henker
gehen wir los und machen wir zurück wir
haben ja jetzt wir sind ja jetzt jetzt
in einer ganz konkreten Situation
bezieht sich ja auf jetzt keine
Perspektive Geschichte jetzt aber sorry
ich bin nicht sozusagen ich verstehe
jetzt sagen woher sie kommen aber wenn
ich einmal kurz mit Fakten rein Stimmen
darf die Atomkraft kann in Deutschland
nicht unsere Energiekrise lösen auch
nicht die Knappheiten 1 % vom Gas kann
erreichbar das heißt aber wir müssen
noch mal in dieser dieser Debatte diese
ganzen wichtigen Räume wo wir über die
Energiekrise reden werden verstopft mit
dieser mit diesen oberflächlichen Atom
Diskussion ohne tiefe ohne dass man
bedenkt was kann die Atomkraft leisten
und was nicht es tut mir wirklich einmal
ganz kurz ich bin ja auch schon mal so
gegrillt worden und andere auch
nicht es geht um die Energie Fragen und
die müssen wir doch grundiert und
informiert zu antworten und es gibt auch
um den Diskurs und ich habe schon
wirklich auch den Eindruck dass dieses
dieser
pseudo-diskurs wir reden über ein
relativ kleinen Anteil am Strom Mix in
Deutschland den das ausmacht über drei
oder vier Monate diese ganze Debatte ist
sehr aufgebauscht sie wird im Internet
geführt polarisiert die Menschen auf der
Straße wollen dass der Strom da ist das
ist kein black Blackout gibt kein
Blackout gibt und dass die Wohnung warm
bleiben das ist einigermaßen bezeichnet
woher der Strom also diese diese
Polarisierung der Debatte ich glaube die
ist ein Beitrag zur Entfremdung zur
politischen Entfremdung weil es hier
wirklich ja also um ein auch in der
Bundesregierung ein gegenseitiges
schuldzu geschaffen ist das tut mir leid
da gehe ich wirklich nicht mit ich muss
mich jetzt einmal wirklich wehren auch
als Bürger dieses Landes und als jemand
der nee ernsthaft also sozusagen zu
unterstellen das ist jetzt hier so ein
bisschen tun Sie bitte nicht persönlich
ne wir nehmen hier nichts persönlich
aber wir reden jetzt mal hart also zu
unterstellen dass es hier um so ein
bisschen Halligalli geht und jetzt wird
medial da quasi irgendwas hochgezogen
was dann angeblich so ein bisschen dazu
da ist die Leute zu benutzen auch in der
Bundesregierung ein ganz entscheidendes
Thema
aber es ist kein halten
wenn du das Argument einmal kurz machen
das ist kein Halligalli da geht es um
existenzielle Fragen es geht um in den
Industrie und Industriestandort
Deutschland es geht darum dass wir die
viertgrößte Volkswirtschaft dieses
Planeten sind es geht darum dass wir
Energiepreise haben die zehn Mal so hoch
sind wie die in den USA es geht darum
das Unternehmen in den USA für ein
Zehntel der Preise produzieren wie hier
in Deutschland es geht darum ganz kurz
nochmal die Fakten über die Fakten es
geht darum dass jemand wie Veronika
Grimm kennen Sie auch Wirtschaftsweise
kluge Frau von der Uni Erlangen die sagt
wenn wir Atomkraftwerke weiterlaufen
ließen hätte das selbstverständlich
Auswirkungen auf den Strompreis 12%
weniger das sind ihre Berechnungen das
ist relevant und gerade jetzt relevant
für viele viele Menschen das ist nicht
Halligalli Wirtschaft sondern immer
gesagt es ist ein sehr teures Modell
gelassen wollen das auch gar nicht
weiterführen dass also das so
mein Thema ist meine Frage ist will ich
hier nicht unterstellen aber ich will
nur sagen sagten gerade das kann man
nicht so an der Oberfläche führen kann
man eben nicht sondern es geht
tatsächlich um die Existenz vieler Leute
und es geht diesem Land an den Kragen
wenn wir diese Energie und Gaspreise
nicht in den Griff kriegen und das ist
der entscheidende Punkt Kraftwerke
Niedersachsen ob das nun verlängert wird
drei Monate unter anderem unter anderem
gerade weil die Lage so essentiell ist
weil sich Menschen das hatte ich auch
schon mal hier in der Sendung ja eben
betont sich so wahnsinnig große Sorgen
machen verdienen ist die Leute doch auch
dass die Debatten so geführt werden dass
sie in annähernd das widerspiegeln was
die Wirklichkeit uns vorsetzt und das
müssen wir jetzt einmal fragen warum
sind denn die Energiepreise so hoch weil
es ein Krieg ist weil wir abhängig
geworden sind von fossilen Energien und
fossilen die uns heute erpressen können
wo die Preise explodieren
aber jetzt Antworten geben für diesen
Winter jetzt geht es darum die Antworten
für jetzt zu geben aber dafür zu sorgen
dass wir auch diese Erpressbarkeit
rauskommen aus dieser Abhängigkeit
rauskommt bis heute ist Russland der
größte uranexporteur Europas
Atomkraftwerke heißt immer auch in
Europa zumindest Putin bestärken wenn
wir von diesem Mann wegkommen wollen
heißt das auch die energiepolitischen
Konsequenzen zu setzen und an der Stelle
geht es nicht darum dass er oder ich wie
jetzt die sitzen und sagen oh wir
sollten man nicht so oberflächlicher her
reden sondern dass sie ja
Energieexperten diesem ganzen Land immer
wieder sagen Leute redet darüber was was
wirklich die Lage entschärfen kann und
nicht das was gut klickt was
populistisch ist irgendwie gut verkaufen
lässt oder sonst was also erstmal finde
interessant dass unser Moderator jetzt
Diskussionsteilnehmer geworden ist
bin ich eigentlich immer aber ich wollte
aber zu dem Argument von ihnen noch
etwas sagen die Polarisierung gefährdet
die Demokratie oder macht es ja wohl ich
sehe es genau umgekehrt
Streit in der Regierung da kann ich ein
Lied von Singen ist immer schlecht aber
dass man in Westdeutschland über
Atomkraft gestritten hat über
nachlässigen wir andere Dinge hat die
Demokratie hergestellt finde ich auch
wann wenn ich jetzt soll man streiten
über energieversammeln gute Argumente
nichts dagegen und zwar so
leidenschaftlich wie wir das hier getan
haben gerne Fakten orientiert da bin ich
bin ich immer dabei aber ich glaube dass
wir kommen vielleicht noch auf das Thema
ja zu sprechen dass etwa bei der
Flüchtlingsfrage oder bei der eure
rettungsfrage oder so ist immer hieß wir
dürfen das nicht diskutieren war glaube
ich ein Problem und wenn wir das jetzt
machen mit wie war das mit der Kernkraft
war das ein Fehler wie sind wertefragen
bei der ist Energiesicherheit wichtiger
als Klimaschutz das braucht in der
jetzigen Lage der Unsicherheit stärkt
doch die Demokratie wenn das streitig
diskutiert entschuldigung darf ich noch
mal ist es nicht abenteuerlich welche
weil jetzt auch mal Anja Meyer Kirche
Stanz ja sagt man in meiner
Jugendsprache welches Stunts wir gerade
hinlegen um sozusagen genau diese
Debatte nicht führen zu müssen meine wir
denken ernsthaft darüber nach Schiffe
irgendwo weit auf dem Ozean draußen zu
parken ölkraft Schiffe
verbrennen dort Öl möglichst weit weg
machen wir natürlich nicht im Hamburger
Hafen weil dann wird man es ja riechen
machen wir schön weit draußen irgendwo
verbrennen Unmengen an Diesel an Öl um
Strom zu erzeugen kaufen
selber nicht machen wollen so das sind
das sind all die Dinge die gerade
passieren wenn wir das so schlimm finden
warum wie kann das sein dass zum
Beispiel der große Teil der sozusagen
der sagen oder ein wichtiger Teil der
Energiekrise gerade wäre natürlich zum
Beispiel substanzielle Einsparung zu
sagen Leute Energie ist ein knappes Gut
insbesondere fossile Energien das ist
sagen das sind kriegsgetriebene
Rohstoffe und wir müssen damit richtig
hantieren wenn die Lage doch so dringend
wenn die Nöte so groß sind wie kann es
sein dass zum Beispiel der ganze Teil
der Debatte wo es darum geht richtig
einzusparen angefangen beim Tempolimit
und weitergegangen über all die
möglichen Möglichkeiten die man hat
diese das gibt ja auch da wieder die
Berechnung das ist eine Frage von wollen
nicht von können und wie kann das sein
dass das ausgeklammert wird und das ist
glaube ich genau der entscheidende Punkt
wenn wir anerkennen wie existenziell die
Lage ist dann müssen wir auch anerkennen
dass dafür Debatten geführt werden die
sich politisch nicht gut verkaufen das
ist zum Beispiel
schnellere Entscheidung zu treffen weil
wir nicht mehr die Zeit haben in der
Krise zu reagieren das heißt Einsparung
zum Beispiel durch das Tempolimit weil
wir eine tatsächlich eine
Verteilungsfrage haben
rettet aber nicht den
Wirtschaftsstandort Deutschland
zu ich bin ja keine keine
Energieexpertin aber was ich feststelle
und zwar seit sagen wir mal seit einem
halben Jahr ist dass wir dass dieses
Land oder die seine Regierung und seinen
Politik und seine Institutionen immer
mehr zu getriebenen werden es geht um
maximalen Pragmatismus und also wenn ich
mir überlege wenn mir jemand am Wahltag
vor einem Jahr vom guten Jahr jemand
gesagt hätte die Grünen werden in der
Regierung dafür sorgen dass
Atomkraftwerke in den streckbetrieb
kommt
Niedersachsen sprechen müssen ja das
hätte doch das hat doch niemand für
möglich gehalten also ich habe aber ich
glaube ganz so trostlos wie wir das hier
gerade miteinander alles darstellen ist
es nämlich gar nicht ich habe das Gefühl
also jeder von uns hat ja auch ein
Alltag und ein Leben das viele Menschen
sich dieser Lage sehr bewusst sind dass
viele Menschen auch das Auto öfter
stehen lassen dass viele Menschen ist
Zeit auch auf die eigene Tasche ein aber
es geht schon darum dass alle ein
bewusst ist dass es was sie sagen sein
kriegsgetriebenes seltenes Gut und Leute
verhalten sich zunehmen
verantwortungsbewusst also wenn man
Klaus Müller den Chef der
Bundesnetzagentur hör nicht so richtig
da sind jetzt Frau Norbert und ich uns
einer Meinung tatsächlich
der sagt wir wir konsumieren gerade
Energie und Gas als Games kann morgen
niemand hält sich meine Sachen es gibt
noch ein bisschen tiefer
meine Eltern haben sich gerade einen
kohlofen gekauft also sorry es gibt also
diese entsprechende deutliche Sprache
das ist ein Unterschied zwischen den ich
glaube es gibt viele Menschen die Eltern
und im ganzen ja das ist schon ich
Empirie und so nicht so gut aber es gibt
halt einfach nein aber man hat doch ein
man sieht doch wie Menschen sich
verhalten gerade ich stelle
Veränderungen fest da sind ja auch ganz
ganz eng eine Gerechtigkeitsfrage mit
verbunden also die Frage wer spart
eigentlich und sparen die die es
wirklich nötig haben ja das finanziell
reinschlägt nicht sowieso schon auch
schon lang die Süddeutsche hat das mal
ausgerechnet die reichsten zehn Prozent
verbrauchen so viel Energie wie die
Ärmsten 40 Prozent würden die reichsten
zehn Prozent so viel Energie verbrauchen
wie der Durchschnitts Wohlstand Mensch
in Deutschland hätten wir in den
Privathaushalten eine Einsparung von ich
glaube 25 Prozent oder ein bisschen ein
bisschen darüber und das ist was was
Menschen bewegt wir haben ein riesiges
Misstrauen in die Frage von sozialer
Gerechtigkeit was dann zu
demokratieverdrossenheit zu Protest und
dazu führt dass Menschen sich weder
repräsentiert nach ernst genommen fühlen
weil das nicht rentiert wird also zu
sagen dass niemand einspart gegenüber
von Menschen mit denen ich zu tun habe
an der Hochschule
studierendengewicht es gibt Menschen die
bis auf die Taschen bis zum letzten
auskehren einfach weiß gar nicht mehr
anders geht gar nicht weil sie so
besonders ökologisch sind das wollen sie
auch gerne sein häufig aber beides nicht
mehr anders geht das Problem ist dass
wir keine gerechte Lösung haben wir
haben keine gerechte Lösungsansätze es
gibt ein bisschen gießkanner hier ein
bisschen Gießkanne dort dann werden mal
die Rentnerinnen vergessen und mal die
Studierenden und dann denkt man doch
wieder an sie aber diese entscheidenden
Gerechtigkeitsfragen die in der
Klimafrage ja genauso auftauchen ja das
ist eine ungleich verteilte
Verantwortung gibt und damit auch eine
ungleich verteilte Verantwortung
eigentlich sich zu verändern im zu
verhalten Energie einzusparen und so
weiter der berühmte Pool in der Villa
ich will das Bild nicht überstrapazieren
aber das sind Dinge die sehr wenig
diskutiert werden im Gewicht zu der
tatsächlichen Auswirkung wenn sie nehmen
vielleicht zu Atom in der Villa ich
hätte ein anderes Beispiel
Gerechtigkeitsempfinden wo normale
Menschen den Eindruck haben dass das
geht mich jetzt zu weit wer sind diese
Leute warum machen die das mit mir wie
finden wir es in dem Zusammenhang wenn
sich zum Beispiel an einem Montagmorgen
mitten im Berliner Berufsverkehr
Menschen an Kreuzungen festkleben und
genau die Menschen von denen sie gerade
reden daran hindern zur Arbeit zu fahren
um schlicht das Geld zu verdienen dass
sie so dringend brauchen wie finden wir
das ist das in Ordnung oder ist das ist
das dann nicht in Ordnung und wenn wenn
sich in Dresden an einem Gemälde was
nicht nur die Sachsen besonders lieben
Madonna zwei Menschen festkleben
wird das die Begeisterung für
Klimaschutz eher jedenfalls in Sachsen
nicht befördern aber ich will gerne weil
sie sagen sie hätten nicht gedacht dass
die Grünen jetzt sowas machen ich finde
wir müssen schon doch noch ein bisschen
tiefer Graben der Bundeskanzler spricht
ja nicht ohne Gründe von Zeitenwende
Herr Steinberg hat hier auf diesem Stuhl
neulich von Zeiten Bruch geredet
wie auch immer man das sieht es ist
etwas geschehen in den letzten Monaten
was zur Erschütterung von Gewissheiten
oder scheinbaren Gewissheiten geführt
hat die erste Gewissheit war kein Krieg
in Europa die zweite Gewissheit war
wohlstandsmehrung die dritte Gewissheit
war Überfluss statt Mangel und die
vierte Gewissheit war irgendwie
funktioniert der deutsche Staat und alle
diese vier gewisser sind erschüttert
wurden das Prinzip Merkel wenn ich das
mal sagen darf was ja gerade beschrieben
hat ja jetzt von dem Herrn einmal den
Gedanken eben sein und deswegen wird die
Friedensfrage friedensethisch und in der
Frage wie reagiert man auf diesen
Angriff sehr streitig diskutiert warum
auch nicht die Frage wohlstandsmehrung
wird natürlich unter
Gerechtigkeitsfragen auch sonst
diskutiert Überfluss statt Mangel und
bei der Frage funktioniert unser Staat
richtig glaube ich in der Tat dass
jedenfalls diese Häufung von Krisen
gezeichnet bitte nicht mehr so
weitermachen kann sie wissen dass ich
bin ein Anhänger einer großen
stadtreform wir müssen schneller werden
haben sie gesagt wir müssen
krisentauglicher werden wir müssen die
Krisen verbindlicher werden und ich bin
da auch eher optimistisch wenn die
Krisen in den wir leben dazu führen dass
wir sagen wir müssen unseren Staat auch
anders aufstellen und mit dem Problem
fertig zu werden und das streitet
diskutieren dann liegt in der Krise eine
wirkliche aber konkret woran denken sie
dann halt wir brauchen glaube ich eine
Bord der Nationalen Sicherheitsrat wir
brauchen ein Krisenstab von Bund und
Ländern wenn man eine wirkliche Krise
hat da muss man ihn auch zur Krise
erklären wie das viele Demokratien
machen die nennen das Ausnahmezustand
durch das Parlament festgestellt
befristet das Parlament beendet dann
muss es auch sein wenn
Ministerpräsidenten und der Kanzler sich
treffen dass dann das auch gilt und
nicht ein Ministerpräsident hinter sagt
ich mache das aber nicht mit oder ein
Landrat sagt das gildet nicht für mich
wir müssen zu Schlüssel Föderalismus ich
glaube auch den bundstärken bei der
nationalen Krisen Vorsorge bei der
kritischen Infrastruktur haben wir noch
gar nicht darüber geredet was da zu sehr
viel zu tun wir müssen nicht nur wenn es
um lng-häfen geht jetzt Schnellbahn
sondern insgesamt schneller Bahn
das führt zu erheblichen Veränderungen
in Planungs-
aber ich will nur sagen auch über unser
Entscheidungssystem in Krisen denke ich
ist jetzt Anlass zu reden und wenn sie
jetzt sagen Frau Merkel ist alle Schuld
wie lange wir immer das noch sagen
Moment
viele sagen das aber sie haben das nicht
gesagt aber wenn ich das mal sagen darf
Frau Merkel war eine Meisterung im
System
aber es war vielleicht zu wenig Zeit zu
wenig Kraft auch mal über die das System
selbst nachzudenken und jetzt ist es
aber nötig und jetzt ist die Chance so
und jetzt kommt diese junge Generation
steckt genau dieses System in Frage
nicht jetzt Frau Neubauer persönlich
aber wir haben gerade die Fotos gesehen
da da kleben sich Menschen an Kreuzungen
fest da gibt es diese
Klimabewegung gerade ist for future die
weltweit unglaubliche Menschenmassen
mobilisiert und man hat das Gefühl dann
steht so eine so eine Graswurzelbewegung
von der her dem es sehr sagt das ist mir
zu radikal das ist kompromissfeindlich
und Frau Meier sagt diese Ansprache
dieser junge Leute die gefällt mir nicht
weil ich plötzlich das Gefühl habe wir
sind sozusagen Schultern allem und und
ich möchte eigentlich mit diesem
Schuldkomplex nicht durch die Welt
laufen jetzt muss ich aber ein bisschen
einschränken auch weil ich habe mir
gerade
die letzte Generation also diese
Menschen die sich festkleben ich habe
darüber lange darf man man sieht ja
immer wunderbare Reportagen darüber wie
Autofahrer ausrasten und so ich habe
irgendwie gedacht eigentlich ist das ein
relativ friedlicher Protest noch also
ich finde es können wir auch mal
aushalten es als Gesellschaft dass
Menschen ein bisschen unangenehm auch
mal werden ja dass die sind also ich war
auch mal jung das klingt ein furchtbarer
Satz sorry
aber und ich hätte ich habe alle
bewundert die irgendwie ich bin aus der
DDR aufgewachsen da gab es fast kein
Widerstand ich fand das toll was in
Westdeutschland passiert dass die die
antiatom Bewegung und so also insofern
man muss auch mal ein bisschen
unangenehm werden das halten wir schon
aus denke ich
ja ich also ehrlich gesagt ich manchmal
fühle ich mich wie in so einem
Paralleluniversum was machen wir denn
hier sie reden über Sicherheit was für
eine Sicherheit soll es geben einer Welt
in der uns die Lebensgrundlagen um die
Ohren fliegen und das heißt ganz konkret
mal eben 150 Tote in der Flut im Aartal
wo man weiß man muss die Menschen besser
schützen die Katastrophen kommen aber
und wir werden Großteil der Katastrophen
wir werden sie nicht aufhalten können
die kommen unsere Infrastruktur ist
nicht bereit dafür die Menschen sind
nicht ausreichend geschützt vor den
Hochwasser wurde in Düren vor den
Ernteausfällen und so Lieferketten sind
nicht geschützt die Ernährungsgrundlagen
sie sind nicht sicher unser
Energiesysteme sie kollabieren wenn das
klimakollabiert es kann doch keine
Kontakte Demokratie geben wie wir uns
das vorstellen mit schönen bisschen
Transparenzen bisschen rum reden mal
gemeinsam eine Runde machen noch mal
abwarten bisschen Zeit um das alles geht
nicht wenn wir für Notstand zur Notstand
schlittern in eine Welt in der sich das
gegen das Klima so unkontrollierbar wird
dass wir keine Möglichkeiten haben damit
zu halten das heißt ich erzählen zu
setzen und zu ja sorry das ist mir ein
bisschen zu radikal oder ja die Leute
die stören die Menschen im Berufsverkehr
warum machen Sie denn das
Punkt waren in dieser in dieser
Gesellschaft in der das so anerkannt
wurde dabei sind die Studien
überwältigen die Wissenschaft ist da
rhetorisch Antonio gitarrez sagt fossile
Energien töten das ist der
UN-Generalsekretär das zu sagen in der
Sprache in dem sprech in den Reden ist
hier alles da aber wenn sich eine
Regierung eine Gesellschaft wie die
deutsche die so eine Verantwortung trägt
das ganze mit verursacht zu haben und so
eine Chance hat das ganze zumindest
abzumildern wenn sie sich nicht in
irgendeiner Weise bereit erklärt sich so
zu verhalten als wären wir in einem so
krassen krisenkomplex das ist eine
Vorstellungskraft übersteigt natürlich
machen dann Leute was was auch immer und
kleben sich hin oder stellen sich auf
die Straße oder protestieren und
ehrlicherweise wenn nur halb so viele
Menschen die jetzt eine Meinung zu dem
klimaprotest hätten eine Haltung zur
Klimakrise hätten dann werden wir in
großen Schritt weiter aber wieder dazu
dass die Leute keine Haltung haben also
das finde ich jetzt ein bisschen
überzogen also dass das ist eine
Unterstellung gucken wir uns an was in
diesem Land passiert und wie wir in den
letzten Jahren und Jahrzehnten diese
Klimakrise immer weiter vorangetrieben
haben statt das große Potenzial zu
nutzen aus den fossilen rauszukommen und
von Putin unabhängig zu machen
Lebensgrundlagen zu schützen hat man
neue fossile Abhängigkeiten geschaffen
hat man die Energiewende systematisch
blockiert hat man dafür gesorgt dass mit
den ganzen Märchen von wir schaffen das
aber die Kinder sind das Problem und das
ist doch nicht so schlimm wie so ein
wabern in so einem Jahr in so einem
Paralleluniversum entstanden ist in der
die Krisen nur dann da sind wenn sie uns
gerade passen oder nur dann irgendwie
relevant sind wenn Greta irgendwas dazu
sagt das ist doch nicht die Welt in der
wir leben
interessant finde sie haben gerade den
drastischen Worten geschildert was da
passiert sie haben gerade darauf
hingewiesen welche katastrophalen Folgen
Umweltverschmutzung
Kohleverstromung Kohleverbrennung was
das hat ich mir die Zahl noch mal
angesehen fünf Millionen Menschen Sch
beispielsweise sterben nur an an
Umweltverschmutzung jedes Jahr
sie sagen das haben sie gerade eben
gesagt wir brauchen krasse Maßnahmen
sonst sind wir hier in so einem
komischen Paralleluniversum aber
trotzdem drücken Sie sich um die simple
Frage ob wir ein paar Atomkraftwerke ein
paar Monate weiterlaufen lassen sollten
oder nicht wenn ich sie nach genau
diesen Kassen Maßnahmen
aber wenn wir davon sprechen dass ich
die Dinge verändern müssen wenn wir
nicht wollen dass ich durch die Krisen
alles verändert dann reden wir nicht von
Kleinigkeiten wie atomfragen dann
sprechen wir von ganz fundamentalen
fragt wir sind unsere Verkehrssysteme
organisiert wie organisieren wir da
nachhaltige Landwirtschaft auch global
wie kann internationale Handel
funktionieren dass wir nicht die ganze
Zeit die eine Hälfte der Welt ausbeuten
und Menschen in die Katastrophen rein
rennen lassen das übersteigt doch das
was wir hier zu sagen im Kleinen haben
auch die Energie Fragen die müssen
geklärt werden aber dahinter stecken
doch ganz große Fragen nämlich wie zum
Henker haben wir vor langfristig als
Menschheit auf diesem Planeten sie
brauchen für krasse Maßnahmen brauchen
sie in Demokratien Mehrheiten und Sie
brauchen international Verbündete sie
brauchen China an Bord sie waren Indien
an Bord so waren die Amerikaner anbauen
das haben die Amerikaner und die Inder
und die Chinesen alle
mit und es gibt eine Bundesregierung die
demokratisch gesagt hat wir wollen uns
an das Pariser Abkommen halten
Klimaabkommen ist mein extra Thema aber
die Umsetzung der Maßnahmen hier die
verlangen eine Mehrheit und wenn Sie zum
Beispiel sagen wir wollen da wäre ich
dafür die Bauzeit von
Eisenbahnschienen halbieren vermehrt
sogar um zwei Drittel verkürzen brauchen
Sie dafür eine Mehrheit das bedeutet Sie
müssen anhörungsrechte beschneiden das
bedeutet Sie müssen Gerichtsverfahren
beschneiden das bedeutet Sie müssen
Wälder durchschneiden das müssen die
Naturschutz beschneiden das müssen sie
alles machen ich bin dafür aber sie
brauchen dazu Mehrheiten und das braucht
Zeit in der Demokratie so lässt sich wie
das wie das ist und deswegen bleibe ich
ja dabei wenn diese Krise die sie
beschreiben ich mache mir nicht alles zu
eigen aber vieles schon dann müssen wir
in der Tat anders entscheiden ist unser
Demokratie als das bisher gemacht haben
aber nicht indem wir irgendwie extreme
Maßnahmen machen sondern indem wir die
Skeptiker überzeugen diesen Weg
mitzugehen
aber die Mehrheiten gibt es ja also die
studien sagen das ja die
einstellungsstück ein Großteil der
Bevölkerung will ein ökologischer
Transformation will aus die aus einer
Krisensituation nicht mit
aber nicht vor der Tür so und und weder
die Leitung
unterirdisch
nein wenn man sich anguckt wie viel wird
in Deutschland tatsächlich von Bürgel
Initiativen blockiert denn es sind es
minimale Anteil und oftmals Stärken
übrigens politische Kräfte dahinter die
die allerersten sind die populistische
sagen wählt uns und ihr bekommt keine
Windkrafträder also das ist jetzt nicht
so als wären Menschen kategorisch nicht
vereinbar und dazu kommt auch übrigens
die Feststellung wir Rennen gegen die
Zeit an also sich herauszunehmen einer
Krise die voranschreite schneller als
wir das Glauben zu sagen wir wollen aber
die Zeit haben dass sie der schlechter
Wirklichkeit wenn die Alternative geht
Zeit oder Demokratie wenn ich für
Demokratie wenn sie sagen wenn wir haben
nicht die Zeit dann möchte ich von ihnen
an Lösungsweg haben wie wir diese
schnelle Zeit erreichen
die Wahl Zwischenzeit und Demokratie
haben wir nicht wenn wir die
fundamentalen Krisen dieser Zeit nicht
in den Griff bekommen wie stellen Sie
sich vor sollen intakte Demokratien in
einer zweigrad-wärmeren Welt aussehen in
der uns die Krisen um die Ohren fliegen
der wir von Notstand zur Notstand
diktiert werden von den krisenumständen
wenn Demokratien geschützt werden wollen
sollen dann doch echte Maßnahmen
überleben und nicht Diktaturen sie
sagten gerade die die diese Wahl haben
wir nicht mehr zwischen Zeit und
Demokratie was heißt das im Endeffekt
der
Klimaschutz der Gerechte Klimaschutz der
schnell kommt das Demokratie schützende
Mittel ist was wir überhaupt haben denn
was wir gerade sehen und ich glaube
viele Menschen haben auch in Corona die
Erfahrung gemacht auch als der Krieg
ausbrach wenn die Notstände kommen dann
werden die demokratischen Räume
eingeschränkt dann nämlich haben wir
nicht mehr die Zeit noch mal rum zu
reden noch mal zu befragen nochmal die
Experten anzuhören noch mal die
bürger:innen dann diktiert der Notstand
und nicht mehr die parlamentarischen
Instanzen nicht mehr die Regierung das
heißt je mehr Notstand da ist desto
weniger Demokratie haben wir deswegen
sagen wir wir brauchen so dringend den
Schutz vor der Notstand das ist ja
Klimaschutz das heißt ja wir verhindern
die schlimmsten Katastrophen damit wir
überhaupt die demokratischen Räume
erhalten die wir haben können und dann
und das ist das wunderbare sind wir auch
in diesen großen Transformationen die
anstellen Energiewende Verkehrswende
Agrarwende ist die Demokratie eines der
wichtigsten Werkzeuge was wir haben die
Menschen mit ihren Ideen mit ihrem
Wissen die vor Ort die Energiewende
selber machen die sind ja das heilige
gut was wir da haben sie wissen ist doch
das Innerste von dem wofür wir einstehen
da können sie wollten die ganze Zeit ich
hätte danach noch eine Anmerkung dazu ja
in der Tat bei das ist kein ist kein
Gegeneinander das hat er das
Bundesverfassungsgericht auch unter dem
mit dem starken Bezug auf die
Freiheitsrechte also geurteilt dass wenn
man das zulässt das ist weiter mit einem
unentschlossenen oder einem nicht
ausreichendem Klimaschutz geht also ein
Klimaschutz der nicht ausreicht um das
1,5 oder notfalls zwei Grad Ziel zu
erreichen dann werden künftige
Generationen massive
freiheitseinschnitte haben ich sehe das
exakt genauso das ist das was auch in
der in der Forschungsliteratur überall
so diskutiert wird es ist kein
Demokratie oder Klimaschutz es ist wenn
wir kein Klimaschutz haben dann werden
wir keine Demokratien mehr haben weil
dann werden sich die faschistischen
Bewegungen durchsetzen dann kommt das
Hauen und Stechen dann kommt die
Verteilungskämpfe dann kommt die Zäune
und der Stacheldraht und man guckt nicht
mehr nach außen hin weil der das
co2-budget wird immer kleiner das noch
verbraucht werden kann darum gibt es ein
massiven Konkurrenzkampf ein massiven
globalen Konkurrenzkampf wir verbrauchen
viel mehr als gerechterweise dazu steht
es wird jetzt schon die Hetze betrieben
in Hinblick auf mögliche
klima-flüchtlinge und die entsprechenden
Entwicklungen damit das hat im
französischen Wahlkampf eine Rolle
gespielt es spielt bei den Protesten die
wir jetzt sehen bei der Agitation eine
Rolle die Demokratie muss und das ist
ganz entscheidend muss viel effektiver
werden und damit auch schneller da bin
ich persönlich da bin ich ganz bei Ihnen
ich inhaltlich war ich nicht überzeugt
ob das ob ein nationaler krisenrat das
beschleunigt das habe ich nicht
verstanden
es kann sein dass es einen bestimmten
Punkten Abbruch Prozesse gibt so wie wir
das im Moment sehen dass man nicht alle
mitnehmen kann das sehen wir aber schon
seit einigen Jahren dass man nicht alle
mitnehmen kann weil nicht alle
mitgenommen werden werden wollen und
diese dann aber eine laute möglichst
laute Minderheit als immer wieder als
Vorwand zu benutzen warum bestimmte
Dinge nicht gemacht werden kann das
bringt uns in eine Sackgasse die dazu
führt dass demokratische Politik immer
ineffektiver wird was dazu führt dass
die Verdrossenheit steigt und diese
populistischen oder auch extremistischen
Kräfte stärker werden insofern glaube
ich sind wir uns einig dass für beides
brauchen wir brauchen eine effektive
demokratische gerechte Gestaltung die
aber in der Lage ist zu verhindern dass
aus Krisen die Katastrophen werden von
denen uns 99
der Wissenschaft warnen